Hey guys,
Just a very quick reminder.
If you watch what's going on in the news - listen
to people - just see actually what's going on.
It's pretty overwhelming.
There's darkness all over the place.
And if you listen to your emotions and other
people in the news - you will feel depressed.
And man, almost feel like -
man, you can't do anything.
But don't fall for that trick of Satan.
Because He who is in you is stronger than
he who is in the world.
Remember
you have also received the Holy Spirit.
The Light of Christ.
That's why Jesus is called the Bright Morning
Star because He brought light into this world.
And He has already overcome this world.
I actually have this shirt on today - the
lion of Judah - and that is exactly
who you have in your corner.
You're not alone in this.
Jesus is with you until the end of the age.
Remember that always.
I love you guys.
See you in the next video.
Bye.